we're going to talk a little bit about
the Raspberry Pi this is the model B
Raspberry Pi I shipped there we go one
Raspberry Pi the Raspberry Pi was aimed
to be a $25 Linux PC it was built and
designed by the Raspberry Pi foundation
here in the UK it's based around one of
the Broadcom ARM chips will run line
itself in SD card the CPU is old mobile
phone technology so to live behind the
times and speed power but it's plenty
fast enough for $25 PC screen the middle
we have the arm CPU with 512 megabytes
of RAM stacked on top it's a cortex ARM
chip it runs around about 750 megahertz
bottom left corner USB power jack takes
five volt pass by power the whole board
HDMI output so plug into anyone's
standard TV connector rj45 network
connection for network access two USB
ports for keyboard mouse Wi-Fi dongles
anything you can plug into a PC across
the top standard audio out jack 300
meters composite video for putting into
your old-school TVs CRT monitors GPIO
headers this has input and output logic
level stuff which allow us to plug in
and play with some extra toys and the
latest one to be used is the camera
connector 25-pound camera plugs into
there I think does 720p video having a
chance play that one myself here and on
the back D SD socket we plug in your SD
card with your flavor of linings your
entire operating system general purpose
input and output header has 27 pins
which can be controlled by software to
be either high or low or red as an input
these pins run between 0 and 3.3 volts
so they can either give you a zero volts
3.3 volts or can read back whether
they're currently having receiving 3.30
zero volts allows us to connect to
electronics things like switches LEDs
buzzers and more complex electronics
like the Arduino we can talk to you
those this is an example project for a
Raspberry Pi GPIO had a four LEDs and
to push buttons a little bit code runs
in the background you press a button and
the LEDs increment like set traffic
lights press the other button and they
decrement so you can go blue green
yellow to red it's a nice simple starter
project this just sits on the GPIO
header and then you can go and write
some code I'll allow you to play around
with the buttons and change the color of
the LEDs there's a nice way into
carrying electronics and get a little
more more complex it's a whole LED
matrix display bar graphs going up and
down v meters getting sideways or even
send this a frame buffer so pixel
animation we can scroll text just by
clicking this on the pie on the
Raspberry Pi squarely in the middle
there we have the CPU and the RAM
these are stacked on top of each other
it's quite tricky manufacturing process
you have a PCB printed circuit board so
on top of that it's the CPU and the RAM
so these chips are BGA chips ball grid
array so there are lots of little
contact points in between the chips and
actually the two ships are soldered on
top of each other if you look at the
example of the inside of the CPU will
look like lots of little civil contact
points so then one in cells are
connected like this it's a problem with
the Xbox is the ball grid array chips in
your Xbox overheats and these solder
joints break down so where they will
fixing them so the thing about the PI
CPU is it also has more of these
connections more of these solder points
on the top it's more sort of around the
outside I'll get bored now and again the
RAM chip has matching connectors they
have to place this CPU perfectly aligned
on these lower connections and then
place the RAM chip perfectly aligned on
the top again and then the whole thing
goes through an oven and the solder
paste is cooked the electric renekton's
made these are a benefit to that size of
the board is the big one because the RAM
chip sits in the same footprint as the
CPU you
have to have it an extra place space
board and you don't have to have all
those ins connecting wires between the
two which also take a board spaces
you've got to break those out and
connect the two wires together and
they're quite high-speed data line so
they need to be laid out very carefully
in order to avoid interference and noise
and lag and all sorts of tricky
electronic engineering problems there's
a whole range of cases this is the
modern white pie stealth case which is
actually branded up with the Eve logo
which was a Coe Kickstarter
project
it's a injection molded clamshell so it
splits in half Raspberry Pi sits in the
bottom okay so goes over the top clips
together and then we have it another
example is the PI by PI Maroney made
here in the UK and Sheffield this is
rainbow laser cut acrylic layers and
this is just bolted together so you just
step the layers onto the Raspberry Pi
again another nice steady case you can
go online download a Linux image from
the Raspberry Pi website flash that onto
your SD card plug your SD card in plug
in HDMI keyboard mouse pair it up and
you have a line X PC you can then
connect it to the network browse the
internet read emails open close files
play rap videos the people behind it
were from the generation of the BBC
micro and the old Commodores and they
were used to the old plug it into a CRT
monitor and just start typing code and
go so there is that squaring for it it's
very heavily aimed around programming in
education and getting kids back into
programming education so this is a $25
computer that it's quite hard to break
if you mess up a file on the operating
system you can just take the SD card out
put it in your computer reload the
operating system back on and stick it in
and you're away again rather than
breaking a Windows machine and spending
three hours trying to reinstall it it's
a little bit more robust classroom full
of these at twenty-five dollars each is
an awful lot less than five or six
hundred band computers could people be
watching this video on eg one a part
exactly yep and play about YouTube
videos there is a separate media center
operating systems list called raspbmc
which is a variation on XBMC which is a
home entertainment and media
to operating system designed to playback
and stream files over the network and
it's quite good at doing up to 1080p
video playback with operating system so
there's a lot of people use these as
media center pcs and they just strap on
the back of their TV have a load of
movies and TV shows on the network
storage and playback and watch through
that bit like driving an early
automobile in the early days you
couldn't rely on an automatic gearbox
you had to know how to change gear it
was the same with the early computers
and got more mesmerised in terms of
keeping the things working and not
crashing and how all that happened
that's how it began